hi everyone this is Jerry this is a live
Flitz game okay this is a game against
1846 player go with the Knight f6 here
alright good actually I was wanting to
play maybe the Benko gambit so let's
let's try this this is I don't play this
often at all so Banco gambit so actually
I didn't even with this f3 that was just
supporting e4 the key features that the
Benko gambit are to just give up a pawn
in order to play along the Queen side so
I'm gonna get my bishop here and
eventually a real play on the B file and
there'll be some pressure on this b2
point hopefully so just Bishop g7 some
developing moves and we'll go with the
knight here to here just attacking in
this light squared Bishop a5 is gonna be
a move maybe even a 4 so let's just get
this pawn rolling try and gain some more
space and try Bishop out here just a
development eventually I want to get my
F rook to b8 possibly and maybe Knight
here so this bishop maneuver that he did
or the the bishop maneuver that white
made earlier here was to counteract my
pressure along this diagonal so I think
this is not correct I think I could just
push here and then this this pawn right
here just this one pun sort of restrains
both of these pawns here so what to do
let's try Queen where do I go out my
queen it seems like I need to be making
a Queen move right here because I want
to get my rook on to b8 so where to go
let's try Queen here actually Queen here
maybe there's thoughts of Queen coming
here let's go with this or first let's
get another piece involved so yeah just
um really the idea here is just to put
pressure on the Queen side and the Benko
and some actually well in some instances
there's some sort of pawn advance here
but I don't think in this case we'd be
doing that so maybe look here to here
just doubling my rooks let's go with
that
my Brooke I mean the only reason I came
here was just to recapture so I want to
just be able to focus everything on this
beat be to pawn right now so heavy
pieces I can't really get anything more
on this file and I'm actually hitting
this Knight here so I just realized that
I think eventually I'm gonna have to
move this Knight maybe here right now
now that wouldn't be good here this is
an unprotected Knight if I do this here
Bishop takes Knight Knight takes Knight
that seems to be just too much
calculating going down there I'm gonna
go with hmm Knight here and if he takes
my Bishop I recapture or just night here
I'm not sure
I want to be able to maybe go here with
my knight but I think that this capture
is gonna be quite good
or if not winning so let's see hmm
let's go with this so the bishops will
be exchange my king will have its head
kind of stuck out here he's susceptible
to checks and that check might actually
come right away
my knight could come here that's one
good thing or not or maybe maybe I
should be doing this followed by Knight
here or maybe first maybe I should be
striking at the in the center right now
let's go with this I do have to watch
out for this diagonal check here so
maybe I could get some stuff going maybe
yeah let's just go with this I'm I'm
able to make some progress now in the
center okay his King is also susceptible
to checks I think my king is actually a
bit more vulnerable than his
unfortunately and these rooks are kind
of my rooks are not great for as long as
my knight is here so probably have to do
something about that let's just push
forward he could check me but I could
come here all right I think that here is
important just to allow my rooks to
guard my seventh-ranked laterally you
probably play rook here and play rook
here if he checks I'll block I want to
what's up great importance in this
position is that I keep my 7th 7th rank
guarded and right now my Knights in a
pin so that's not a great position to be
in so Queen here is a multi-purpose move
it's supporting this advance and it's
also preventing a white rook from
landing itself on e7 different okay so I
could actually check and alright so this
is actually a really good move I'm
pretty sure because now my knight as I
is I could still get this move in my
night can move my queen will be hitting
the night where does the Queen go here I
think it might have to or not why did I
miss that
let's see um I'm in a rough spot here
my Queens being attacked there's dogs
barking outside that's why I missed that
these dogs are distracting me all right
so what do I do here um Queen here or
maybe I should just take yeah let's go
with take yeah maybe maybe this night I
could take advantage of this night being
here let's try this fork forking
possibilities Knight g3 and his queen
can't go too far I don't think I guess
my queen can't go too far either all
right so I'll play here this was a
strong move so this rook really I mean
it was guarding this pawn so actually
maybe this is an idea I could maybe come
here if he checks me what do I do
ty blach probably not because then Queen
takes if check if I play rook here the
Queen takes so this is a strong move
repositioning the knight and also uh
let's get let's go here just to get out
of possible checks so Knight here might
be a good choice I'm thinking Queen here
let's just do this Queen here with ideas
of Knight here
yeah actually this could be a really
annoying Knight if I'm allowed to get
here hopefully I could of checking
possibilities I'll be hitting the rook
here so what is he gonna do actually I'm
threatening to maybe just take here this
rook can't go too far it has to stay on
this file because it's having to defend
against this rook
oh this is a this is a strong move it's
gotta be right
oh but my Knights in a pen can I chase
the Queen away anyhow all right in some
way let's go with my king is like going
a bit crazy so rook here is gonna be
strong I'll just block so my king is
walking a tightrope here so I still have
lots of knight takes here what else do I
have
pawn push this is a passed pawn so I
have a passed pawn a Tudor you know he
has a so I could do this am I missing
something
let's just do that for starters and then
let's just pile up here if he takes my
knight he's in rough shape I don't think
his Knight could really contribute his
knight is just a bit too out of play I
think I'm just gonna be capturing here
let's try this I think he's gonna get
made it yeah he gets made it doesn't he
if he takes yeah Queen takes and then
whatever he does I go here and it's me
am I wrong I don't know I just captured
here no matter how he defends Oh
so this Knight is actually really well
placed Wow
that was a pretty crazy game I'm not
sure how else to describe that one
luckily it worked out well so um thanks
that's all for now
take care bye
you